We all have strange sounding
but delicious tasting food combinations that we just love.
Mine is like bananas, dipped in sour cream and Baco bits.
I got it from my mom. I thought she was nuts.
She forced me to try it.
It was delicious.
So, we're gonna get help today
from one of our dearest friends on the show.
I would like to introduce him now, Eitan Bernath.
Hello.
Hi, Eitan.
Hi. I'm super excited to be here.
Oh my goodness.
Social distance hug.
I know. I've been stalking you on Instagram.
I saw you at the beach,
and you've got your big New York apartment.
Yes.
So excited for you.
Well, I'm now a New Yorker as well.
I know.
So fun.
And I'm very excited for this food.
Me too. So since the beginning of our show,
Eitan and I have had this fun thing that we've done together
which is celebrity food combinations.
The best.
A celebrity that you know and love
has a weird food combo.
We all do.
Eitan,
All right. Let's do it.
We'd like to try it.
Okay, so first up
comes from one of my favorite humans on earth, Cardi B.
I love Cardi B.
Love Cardi B.
She posted a video of rapper, Offset
adding cheese dip into his ramen.
She was disgusted by it.
But I must say,
it is actually something
that's classically eaten by Korean people.
As a comfort food, they put American cheese
into their soupy ramen,
and I think it's gonna be good.
One of my friends, Manny, always does this,
and I tried it once.
Cheese and ramen is delicious.
I didn't know that that was like a thing-
Yeah.
to put cheese on noodles-
Not this type of cheese.
in Asia.
But okay, let's just try that.
Okay. Listen. I mean, I love a noodle so much that I feel
"Am I-?" Are you chopsticking it?
Oh yeah me too, Eitan.
I think we are. Ready?
See, great minds thinking alike.
Okay. I'm going to do the like...
There's nothing wrong about that.
Nothing wrong about it.
Maybe you disagree?
You like it? Yeah?
I'll take that as a yes.
It's really interesting
because
this taste of cheese
never comes with like the permy ramen noodles.
I'm into it.
It's like you're having like spicy nachos with like-
Bouncy noodles.
ramen.
Yeah.
It's like, it's two different cultures.
Kind of feels like a college food.
Dude, I still to this day,
can't find a ramen I love out there
as much as Top Ramen.
Okay, so next up. This one, I'm a little excited for.
So this one comes from rapper, Saweetie.
She posted a video where she puts ranch dressing
all over her spaghetti and tomato sauce.
Now, one thing you're doing-
she supposedly dunks in it like a lot.
That was why there was a whole Twitter debate
over "Is she crazy?"
So I'm trying to be, keep authentic.
Okay. My mouth just watered though.
'Cause like really weird...
All right, here we go.
That's what we do, Eitan.
We do like the celebrities do.
Oh yeah.
Fine dining at its best.
All right, here we go. Ready?
I also don't hate it.
I don't hate it either.
I really don't.
I know.
It's actually really good.
Saweetie, you're a genius.
We're on your side of the Twitter debate.
Like Offset,
yes.
Saweetie,
I know that's two for two, Eitan. Not bad.
The last one is pickles
with peanut butter chocolate cups.
Okay. That is just- who is the weirdo
slash possible genius who came up with this combo?
The one and only Selena Gomez.
She told Bon Appétit
that pickles with Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
are supposedly delicious.
She said, it's a combination that just works
for so many reasons.
I don't know those reasons, but we may find out.
Do you know what's so funny, Eitan?
The power of celebrity.
I was like, this seems like weird.
And then when I said "Selena Gomez", she was like-
I was like-
"Oh, okay."
"Well, maybe."
'Cause it's Selena.
I'm thinking of like a sandwich.
Like, do you like a little pickle sandwich?
Oh. See, Eitan. That's why you're you.
I would've never thought to sammie.
Cheers.
All right, cheers.
Love you.
It's not terrible.
This one, I'm not sure I get.
Out with the pickles, in with the cup.
The peanut butter cup is so good,
but half sour pickles are like my favorite thing
on the planet.
I love pickles too.
And I love Reese's Peanut Butter Cups so like...
But not together.
Yeah, no.
They're not a match made in heaven.
I didn't think there wasn't a thing in the world
that Selena Gomez couldn't convince me of, but-
We found it.
And hopefully, we may pick her brain one day.
Yes. That'll be fun.
Well, I loved this.
Eitan, can we please do this again ASAP
and get more weird celebrity food combos?
I'm always down. You know me.
Oh good, Eitan. I love you.
(upbeat music)